mmm assuming the t-shirt means you saw
me in my underwear yep can't get enough
of the kissing booth well you're in luck
because there's some great bonus content
in the form of deleted scenes from the
first movie they came out just in time
to help us get the hype out about
kissing booth - isn't it great when
things work out like that
this was almost a pretty different movie
but regardless of what was cut we can't
wait for the sequel and we've got all
the details Lee I can explain
unbelievable sometimes long-term
friendships can get messy so Elle Evans
and Lee Flynn made up some rules to make
being platonic pals a little bit easier
one role that comes into play in the
kissing booth is no dating each other's
relatives this might not be so hard to
follow except for the fact that Lee
happens to have an extremely handsome
older brother named Noah that Elle has a
serious crush on when L and Lee created
kissing booth for a school fundraiser
Elle tries to convince Noah to offer up
his lips and the interest of school
spirit of course Alan Noah end up
confessing their feelings to one another
you are the only girl who doesn't fall
on my feet and it is driving me crazy
which puts a strain on her friendship
with leave but thankfully the three are
able to sort things out before Noah
heads off to college now that we're
caught up on what did happen in the
movie let's take some time to talk about
what almost took place fans couldn't get
enough of the cuteness between Alan Noah
so Netflix provided us with some new
deleted scenes to obsess over before
they get ready to drop the kissing booth
- let's take a look at some of the
character interactions that didn't end
up making the final cut we totally
understand why L wanted to convince Noah
to work at the kissing booth and that
she wanted to impress the OMG girls you
have to admit she maybe doesn't have the
best timing in the movie she decides to
ask no it the OMG girls want to know if
you'll do our kiss
when he's already in the process of
making out with someone else
needless to say this didn't go over well
with Noah's date and although he
advocated to L he still definitely said
no about taking part in her project but
in this deleted scene I'll try this
slightly better tactic of ambushing Noah
after he finishes using the restroom
hey it's not ideal but at least his lips
are free to talk in the scene first she
tries to butter him up by complimenting
his arms nice arms man but obviously
Noah isn't impressed by her transparent
attempts at flattery
he asks what she wants and she pitches
the kissing booth idea I'm just saying
they're so helpful if you would do
because they cancel oh yeah and the good
news is she doesn't get a no but the bad
news is that she gets a man that's it
[Music]
which is kind of worse Elle doesn't take
knife for an answer and says he owes her
for telling guys not to date her and
orders him to both take part in the
dance clubs kissing booth and stay out
of her personal life but despite her
commands Noah just brushes her off and
walks away even though no it turns her
down either way it was nice to see a
more confident L with a better plan than
interrupting him mid makeout she also
had the chance to thank him for covering
for her about what the first day of
school fight was really about even
though Noah called her Miss Perfect in a
joking way in the deleted scene oh well
I didn't want to ruin your dad's image
of Little Miss Perfect it's cool to hear
him acknowledge that he was trying to
stick up for her in front of her dad
either way else requests for Noah to
work the kissing booth was denied and
while the cut version was a bit sweeter
it was missing the drama of the big
party asked as exciting this prom can be
sometimes the themes get a little bit
repetitive but a deleted scene showed us
that Elle's prom almost had a way cooler
one we saw the committee voting on the
theme and at one point it was a
neck-and-neck tie between memory lane or
zombie prom night that might have been
the best prom theme of all time but
sadly the deciding vote went to memory
lane I vote for the
theme which is what we saw happening in
the movie even though we sadly didn't
get to see zombie prom we did get to see
Noah recreate the kissing booth and
confess his feelings for Elle in front
of everyone I'm telling you that I love
you but there were some slight
differences regarding how it played out
in the movie what we saw was Elle
rejects Noah's confession for fear of
hurting Leigh and then run out of the
prom
although these girlfriend Rachel chased
her L didn't turn back and kept running
off into the night that girl really
loves to run away from things quite
literally but in the deleted scene I'll
actually stop song enough to talk to
Rachel for a little bit before she had
tome Rachel asks if she's okay
and Elle says she wishes she didn't come
to prom at all she insists Rachel and
lease stay and enjoy the dance and tells
Rachel carefully Crispin and asks her to
be a good girlfriend to leave although
it's a little less dramatic than seeing
her simply storm out it's nice to see
Ellen Rachel having a caring interaction
in the movie Elle gets home from prom
and she finds a gift her dad left on her
bed inside is a framed and science photo
of her late mom it's touching but not as
much as the scene we almost saw in the
deleted scene else dad actually tried to
stay awake to greet Elle when she got
back from prom he asks her how's the
prom and said that since it's after
midnight
he wanted to wish her a happy birthday
it's a simple moment between father and
daughter but it seems more personal and
realistic than the signed photo left on
the bed her birthday
there are also some deleted scenes which
are just plain fun including some extra
footage of parties that didn't make it
into the final cut there's also a
moments when Al learns a little
something extra about Noah that he wears
Superman boxer shorts
apparently the coolest guy in school is
a comic book fan and Al tries to use
this info to blackmail Noah into doing
the kissing booth but even that doesn't
work and Noah angrily orders her to get
out
nice try el Elle's dad gets choked up
watching his little girl get ready to go
to her prom and even her little brother
is impressed with how beautiful she
looks but in a deleted scene that only
does she get some appreciation from her
family but she also gets a car maybe her
dad was just tired of Al constantly
struggling to get rides from other
people there was also almost a moment
when Elle's brother Brad almost catches
her and know it together prompting him
to hide in the closet thinking his big
sis is gone Brad jumps up and down on
the bed before expressing himself a
little too much thankfully he had the
courtesy of spraying some Febreze
afterwards did see in these extra
moments make you want to watch the
kissing booth all over again wow that's
definitely never a bad idea don't forget
to start getting the hype for the sequel
yes Ellie and Noah are all coming back
to the sequel in this Netflix film
like the first movie the kissing booth -
is also based on a book by Bath Regals
the book is called the kissing booth -
going the distance and you'll be happy
to know that the cast you loved in the
first movie is coming back for the
sequel joey king will be reprising her
role as el evans while joel courtney and
jacob oh lordy will be back his brothers
Leah Noah Flynn respectively in addition
to the actors we know and love from the
first film there will also be some
exciting additions to the cast you might
have seen actress amazing Richardson
sellers in DC's legends of tomorrow
permissible sir I'll fly ahead and
record crakers movements sensible or in
the movie Star Wars Episode 7 the force
awakens as corsola and now she's going
to be part of the kissing booth - as a
character named Chloe then we have
Taylor's that car Perez who worked on
the series embeds and will be playing a
character named Marco in the movie that
only are we excited about seeing Maisie
and Taylor joined the kissing booth crew
but based on this fun introduction video
so are the existing cast members because
of the Cova night team pandemic a lot of
highly anticipated shows and movies are
being pushed back because of new
restrictions making production difficult
while it's completely understandable
it's also disappointing for some fans
who can't wait to see what comes next
but you don't have to worry about that
with the kissing booth - because
production has wrapped up Joey king
confirmed via Twitter that she spent her
last day as all evans in south africa
back in august 2019
so when can you expect to start
streaming the kissing booth - is set to
hit Netflix on July 24th 2020 so really
the answer is not soon enough
now that we know when it comes out of
course we want to know what's going to
happen Joey King says she hopes Ellen
noaa's stays together and even has plans
for their future career she thinks they
should get into the theme park business
and become a power couple who creates
amazing rides and attractions
considering how much L managed to mess
up the actual kissing booth this might
not happen but it's still a fun idea so
maybe if you
just stop by the booth for a little I
don't know I just it would mean a lot to
me
Jacob oh lordy is coming back for the
sequel but it turns out he's not
actually the biggest fan of his
character Noah he actually called Noah
kind of awful and although he enjoyed
working on the movie he doesn't get why
people idolize his character so much
maybe we'll get to know more about Noah
in the sequel and see a softer side to
this cool guy you are complicating the
film process was the fact that Joey and
Jacob dated in real life after working
on the kissing booth according to Joey
their breakup was hard not just on her
but fans of Noah and Elle but don't
worry because these stars were committed
to not letting their real-life
relationship impact the kissing booth -
Joey admits it was a wild experience but
says it helped her grow both as a person
and an actor plus not only was it a good
career move but Joey is a huge kissing
booth fan herself and even she wanted to
see what happens between Alan Noah even
if it involved sharing screen time with
her ex in a sequel Noah is off to
Harvard while Elle enjoys her senior
year of high school long-distance
relationships are never easy especially
when Ella meets her new classmate Marco
and Noah meets a woman named Chloe in
college will they be able to work it out
or will they realize that absence
doesn't always make the heart grow
fonder fans at the franchise are just
going to have to wait to find out are
you excited for the follow-up to the
kissing booth or do you think it should
have been one and done
let us know if you're looking forward to
the adventure continuing and if you
think any of the deleted scenes from the
first movie should have been kept in the
final cut don't forget to stay connected
with us here at the things by clicking
subscribe and turning on your
notifications bye for now